now to Ukraine where the country's
President says hundreds of thousands of
people could lose access to Safe
Drinking Water after a major dam was
attacked and destroyed in a
russian-controlled region of Southern
Ukraine flood waters are still Rising
Downstream from the dam in some 2 000
people have been rescued Deborah patta
is in Ukraine with the latest on the
disaster
the sheer magnitude of this catastrophe
is becoming clear as water continues to
Surge through the breached wall of the
collapsed Dam towards her son less than
50 miles away homes have been submerged
many just swept away and once fertile
agricultural grounds now a soggy
Wasteland it has triggered an
environmental catastrophe endangering
drinking water and an entire ecosystem
and a humanitarian crisis forcing the
evacuation of thousands even as War
continued to rage around them for the
people of her son who endured months of
Russian fire only to be chased from
their homes by Rising water it is too
much when you live here for more than
six months after being bombed all the
time after being scared all the time
it's trying to stay see there is anger
I know it's War said but to blow up the
dam it's barbaric
and there it is this man cursing Russia
non-stop as he waded through the murky
water carrying his 80 year old mother's
remaining possessions
the dam holds back a reservoir
containing about the same volume of
water as the Great Salt Lake in Utah and
is important for the safe running of the
kremlin-controlled zepparisa nuclear
power plant the United Nations atomic
energy body says that plant is safe for
now and the Kremlin has denied any
involvement in blowing up the dam
but the office of the prosecutor General
in Ukraine has told CBS news that they
are investigating this as a Russian war
crime calling it ecoside Tony
Deborah powder for us once again in
Ukraine Deborah thank you very much